on the roads of southern Iceland in the
grip of a state of emergency but the
people in these cars aren't fleeing the
danger zone they're desperate to get to
it it's unreal it's like a very lousy
movie ah it's going to
erupt but I just hope it doesn't start
in the middle of the Town Enad dardon is
one of 4,000 people who fled the town of
grindavik on Friday he left with his
82-year-old mother after a swarm of
powerful earthquakes and warnings of an
imminent eruption now you always have to
look at at the bright side nobody is
dead and
and triple the size of gr people are
dead in Gaza half of them children
emergency crews have given residents a
window of just a few minutes each to
collect important documents treasured
possessions for Anar an airline pilot
that includes his uniform he's due to
fly to the us on Saturday can you allow
yourself to think about when you'll be
back and what's going to happen I'm not
thinking about it just get my stuff if
it if it all goes then we'll leave the
we leave it all here the haste comes
from the scientific predictions an
eruption within days is thought likely
if it comes Under the Sea the
interaction with the water would cause a
huge ash cloud Anar and his neighbors
are worried about it happening on land a
possible huge outflow of lava that
destroys their town for the Emergency
workers overseeing this operation this
is a new level of Crisis even for
Iceland with all its geological
volatility it's quite out of the
ordinary it's not something that we're
used to but it is something that we do
train for and we have plans for well
it's late afternoon now not long before
Sunset and still there is this enormous
cue of people trying to get into the
town for some it's a chance to try and
get treasured items what they need for
the extent of this evacuation others
though are worried about this being a
last chance ever to see their homes
Harry forcet Al jazer Southern
Iceland make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer